la situation est à l'image de celle qui
prévaut dans l'ensemble il le franc
c'est une situation préoccupante le
premier ministre a parlé de l'arrivée de
la vague épidémique
c'est effectivement la situation à
laquelle est confrontée l'ensemble de
l'ile-de-france et des yvelines au sein
de l'ile-de-france
non pas ce week-end il y a un énorme
effort dans l'ensemble des hôpitaux
d'île de france et aussi dans les
hôpitaux des yvelines pour augmenter la
capacité d'accueil en particulier en
lits de soins critiques ou en lits de
réanimation l' agence régionale de santé
a fixé un objectif de doublement des
capacités pour la semaine prochaine et
les hôpitaux des yvelines sont en
capacité de faire face à ce défi en
mobilisant toutes les énergies
l'ensemble des hôpitaux à la croix des
hôpitaux publics comme les hôpitaux
privés comme les cliniques qui
participent collectivement à l'effort
c'est un effort très intense mais il ya
une formidable mobilisation de
l'ensemble des équipes médicales
pour relever ce défi du nombre de lits
de réanimation